what is the producer's rep it's like a
sales agent
it's another name for a sales agent so
um in the it usually connotes being a
domestic sales agent as opposed to an
international sales agent
it's a little different in that as a
producer rep you are
selling films to U.S distributors
and in doing so there's you don't really
have to take over the film from the
filmmaker you can make the deal you can
negotiate on their behalf and then they
can deliver the film to the distributor
and distributor can pay them directly
it's a fairly easy transaction
whereas on the international front
International sales agents really have
to take over that process so
International sales agents are more like
distributors in that you deliver them
the film
and then they go to markets around the
world sell these Distributors and then
in turn
deliver the film to those Distributors
collect that money and then account to a
um a producer
so in my case I don't do it I don't do
that I specialize in U.S Distributors
and as most producer apps do
and I'm just I'm like a like a
consultant sales agent for that purpose
between a producer's rep and
so a producer rep is really trying to
get the film maker the best deal
possible in the United States with a
with a traditional distributor
um
Distributors are are taking on the film
played in theaters
put it on video and demand
making Blu-rays
selling the rights to Netflix or HBO and
putting on an advertising video on
demand later like 2B or Pluto so they're
usually most Distributors are handling
all rights that way
as a producer rep
I'm mean the filmmaker usually about the
time they finish the film or about to
get into film festival or just got into
a film festival and I'm going to help
them get into the world of distribution
and show the film to the Distributors to
see who would be the best possible
partner for taking the film out
why would a filmmaker hire a producer
rep well especially if you're a first
time filmmaker most schools don't teach
film distribution
and so there's just a huge learning Gap
um in terms of like what distribution is
and what they do and usually I consider
my part of my job as education in terms
of teaching my clients what Distributors
do and which Distributors do it better
than who
um and part of my job is to know who's
doing it legitimately and who's not
doing it legitimately and who takes an
appropriate distribution fee for putting
the film out into the world who's kind
of trying to rip them off
um and so it's to protect them as well
um so there's there's really just the
knowledge of distribution that's one
reason another is just protection
um
uh and in addition some salesmanship
um I'm trying to get the best possible
deal out there and some filmmakers you
know a filmmaker in theory could wear
all those hats if they got to learn the
distribution landscape and learn who all
the Distributors are and learned how to
negotiate these contracts and had a
sales hat in addition to a creative hat
there are those types right that that
could do it all
um I'm here for the ones that don't you
know and producer reps in general are
there for the people who can't you know
that need some help in that in that area
have you ever experienced that where
someone says you know I went to AFM I go
on IMDb Pro and I see what similar films
are who they're with and I just can't
navigate this can you help me
yeah all the time because there's
um there are a lot of different kinds of
people at AFM like they're sales agents
versus Distributors sometimes they do
both there's been increasing trend of
some International sales agents getting
into U.S distribution
their contracts look a little bit
different than what U.S Distributors
agreements look like
um and so
um yeah I get it all the time that from
filmmakers you know hey they can't get
the Distributors to call them back
um you know there are some Distributors
that are pretty good have an open door
policy of looking at lots of material
and there's some Distributors that just
want to really use the system of agents
and Reps that are out there to to kind
of be a
um kind of a buffer against all the
content that's out there they don't need
to see 10 000 movies this year they want
to look at the top three or four hundred
which to choose the 20 they might
distribute that year so
um it just yeah most most filmmakers
um
when they go to FM AFM is a great
learning process but it's not a great
really a great tool for independent
filmmaker to go to and actually sell
their own film it usually
um they experience it once they'll
they'll find it's really hard to get in
those doors to meet with Distributors
and most Distributors and sales agents
want to keep Keep the Wolves at Bay so
to speak of course so if a filmmaker
says well I'm very Hands-On and DIY I'll
I'll be the one to break through it's
kind of like they're breaking protocol a
little bit that's not how it's yeah it's
well it's not that it's not okay it's
just that there are there are some
companies that it's just hard to get a
return phone call they're just busy
dealing with the Reps and agents for
film and they're they're getting some of
these companies are getting five six
submissions a day
and some of them they just completely
ignore they just look at it and think I
don't know what that is there's just
there's just too much in coming
um so it helps to have someone that
knows them that says hey I can vouch
this is something you should take a look
at it's not crazy for you to look at
this you may not like it you may love it
but it's something you should you know
pay attention to
um you know that's one aspect of it but
it even more than that
um there are some doors that it's
they're easy to get into but you
shouldn't go through them
right there's some people that just
don't have your best interests at heart
they're just there's a lot of
um in my opinion companies that just
don't do it properly and take exorbitant
fees
um don't cap their costs don't do things
that they should do to to to help their
the their client the filmmaker
um you know maximize revenues for them
as well as for the company that took on
the film
so um
um yeah so there's there's multiple
reasons to have a rep
um I think you know beyond just be able
to get in the door
[Music]
um
but I you know I've known there are also
people that make film after film after
film and establish relationships where
they can just do that themselves as well
especially first time second time
filmmakers that have a hardest time
which are most independent filmmakers
um at the end of the day of the of the
10 000 made a year it's 9 000 plus
they're either first timers
um you know to a certain degree
so it's not just um helping you get in
the door it's also maybe helping you
stay away from doors that are open that
yeah shouldn't be venturing into for
sure and and even if you knew it's also
maximizing the best possible situation
um even if you get in all the right
doors
um you know it's helpful to have someone
that's had a a deal through this
distributor and how to film through this
streamer and knows what it's like to be
in bed with them to knows you know how
good are they at communication how good
are they return your phone calls
um what are their royalty Reports look
like
um do they send them to you consistently
because it's not only the contract you
have to worry about it's the behavior
behind the contract right because it's
fairly easy for Distributors to kind of
ignore a lot of different aspects of
their contract because it's just the
distribution contracts are just hard to
sue on they're all very distributor
friendly Distributors are not going to
make overtly producer-friendly contracts
in general
um so even more important than the
contract is is the habits and behavior
and you know have been in the business
for 25 years I've just seen a lot of a
lot of behavior so to speak so
um
um I think that's pretty helpful
sure and these are these are contracts
that only the distributor draws up if
someone couldn't say I've actually have
my own boiler plate yeah you know it's
always a new Distributors contract in
fact you should be actually wary if it's
not their contract because that probably
indicates they don't know better and
they haven't been doing it very long I
have seen that before where I got it
actually not too long ago someone came
to me with a film and they already had
an offer from someone and I said okay
um did they have a did they send you a
contract I could look at for you and
they said no they wanted us to sit and
do the contract
as well there they can't be that
sophisticated if they if they're out
there acquiring films and wanting you
know you to come up with the contract
that's just pretty pretty it's a good
sign that they're just not very savvy
Glenn how do you get paid please tell us
a couple different ways
um
so
um always a commission
um a percentage of whatever my filmmaker
makes
so there's an advance from uh the
distributor or royalties paid later on I
usually get a commission on whatever and
and that's that's a negotiable
commission uh depending on the
circumstances of the film whether it's
already in a major festival or if I'm
working on from the beginning we can
negotiate what the commission is
um often I also work for a consulting
fee as well
um because I spend you know most
producer reps
I would say
um you know tend to throw films against
the wall see if they stick if they don't
make the deal
move on
um I deal with very much true
Independent films that need a lot of
hand-holding and a lot of tender living
care and so I fashion myself as both
kind of a producer rep and a consultant
so I'm usually paid an upfront fee in
addition to my commission really to help
with the fact that I'm going to
negotiate the contract I'm going to
handle all that I'm going to spend time
with them to make sure they understand
the industry understand the buyers under
you know help out maybe getting them in
their national sales agents so I try to
I try to Fashion myself as kind of a
distribution consultant and a producer
rep
are all your fees uh like one-time fees
or are there any that are continual just
one time one time was just one time yeah
it's usually an upfront fee and then um
in the way I do it I don't I don't put a
term on my my deals I'm I feel like I'm
hired for however long it takes me to
get the film distribution
um or a festival I'm also brought on as
a festival Advocate quite often so
that's part of the the fee structure is
that I'm going to Advocate the film to
festivals programmers I've gotten to
know over time to try to help it get
some kind of promotional boost before we
sell the film so I've gotten to know a
lot of programmers over the years so
sometimes I'm brought in pre-festival
um to call programmers and just make
sure they're watching the movie
um also to pitch it but I think the
biggest thing there is just to make sure
they're watching it
um you know if you add up the number of
you know entries into these festivals
and you look at the number of people
that are been hired to watch them it's
almost impossible right that this few
number of people are watching this
number of movies over a three-month
period so their films some films are not
getting watched or they're just being
watched by an intern or an underlying so
I'm there to try to make sure that
someone
um of significance is watching the movie
and giving a chance
um in addition to maybe Consulting my
filmmakers on what festivals to apply to
is it right for Sundance is it a South
by Southwest kind of movie
um if not is it more of a Heartland
Seattle there's all kinds of great
festivals but you know there's different
festivals of different strategies so I'm
here for that you know kind of in
addition to everything else have you
ever had filmmakers say skip the
festivals I I I know it won't get into
this one and I won't get into that one
and these other ones I don't care as
much about absolutely
um
and you know from an advisory point of
view I've even said that too to some
people that
um
uh your film isn't right it's commercial
um it's um you know if you have a family
movie right
um Sundance doesn't take a lot of family
films and they have they I mean they
might have a section where they take
like one or two really you know big
family films but they're not going to
take small kind of dog or Pony movies
right those kind of movies
um aren't right for festivals
um horror films you know in general
um of a certain level don't there's a
horror audience out there that doesn't
really require kind of lift of a film
festival to to get it um out there and
to a certain degree
festivals really only add so much value
these days to a film festival the real
value at least pre-covered for me for of
Sundance and South by and Tribeca
those are festivals that are attended by
buyers and so they're in a room they're
feeling the audience watch the movie
um it's the only place where
Distributors make mistakes right where
they where they like they they get a
feeling like okay let's go bid on the
movie off of this feeling they have in
the theater
um they're never gonna have that feeling
when they're watching the film on their
cell phone while they're driving or or
however they're they're watching your
movie right
um it's um so those festivals in
particular have that in addition to some
branding value they also have the value
of having the people there watching the
movie
there's another several thousand film
festivals in North America the buyers
just don't go to really great festivals
um
and maybe one or two show up because
they're on a panel or something but
they're not flocking there to watch the
content to see if there's films to buy
they know that at some point those films
will eventually get to them and they'll
be able to watch it in their office it's
not worth flying all over the country to
see these to these festivals
um and the so the value to a distribute
the value there is maybe if we have a
film that's not right for Sundance
didn't get Tribeca Etc but it goes to
Seattle
then we're going to go into the
distributor saying hey here's this great
movie and it just premiered in Seattle
check it out and you pitched the movie
and then they watch it and take you now
now the fact that it's in Seattle goes
in one ear and out the other right it's
not a heavy consideration for them like
oh wow it played Seattle not the one
with flux Miguel all kinds of hate mail
about Seattle but Seattle is a great
Festival but the buyers just aren't
there and so the Distributors are going
to watch it on Vimeo at that point or
Blu-ray
um so
um
there's just there's just marginal value
for festivals at that point but there's
lots of other good reasons to go to
festivals other than will it get
distribution because of them
um you know it's the best experience uh
you have with the film usually uh
experience it with an audience it's
better than theatrical per se where it's
which I feel it was kind of cold there's
not like a ready willing audience uh you
go to limley and you've there's five
seats filled and it just doesn't have
the same impact as a as a festival
screening where people are there to you
know to purposely enjoy a film like they
really want to enjoy it
um
and um other reasons are uh to get
feedback from fellow filmmakers to see
other people's films to meet other
people you might work with in the future
to maybe someone who wants to invest in
your next movie there's all sorts of
good things that come out of festivals
but really for setting up distribution
there's it's really minimal what what
they what they provide for that
um
um so when I'm talking to filmmakers
I have to kind of deal with their
expectations of what they want to do and
give advice on like how to proceed
strategically to get the film the best
possible position and usually I'm going
to say if it's not a Sundance or a South
buyer Tribeca kind of film we can go for
vessels and do that but at any time if
you get tired of that and you're like we
haven't gotten to the festival can we go
ride the bars we can because
it's only providing a little bit of
color to the fact that you've got a good
film already in my view
um
so and so when filmmakers do come to me
and say
let's just go straight to buyers no
problem
um really no problem at all
um it's to a certain degree too
um
some
um I I've had you know there are places
like there's some streamer a couple of
streamers
um that I've approached the films before
and they once a film's in a festival
they've already kind of
looked at it not not that they've seen
the film but they've kind of digested
what it is
and made an assessment
um
purely off of an image and a synopsis
we want to check that out or we don't
um there's a lot they don't
so I've had a little bit more success
with some films especially documentaries
if I'm going to them without anything
and saying hey this has not been exposed
anywhere in the world no festival or
anything I'm giving you and a few other
people a look at it first
sometimes that's a better message to a
distributor than hey we played Seattle
because sometimes I'll get yeah we
looked we saw it in the listings not for
us you know you'll get sometimes then
I've got to beg and plead them to watch
it and give it another chance so
um
yeah it's uh
you know at the same time though
lots of filmmakers just want to play
festivals right they just that's just a
thing and I very understandably there's
a lot of great stuff about it so
you know the I'm here to advise on
strategy and then once we've decided
with the filmmaker what to do then I'll
implement it whatever kind of whatever
they want to do
so they want to play festivals do they
also want to attend or some are okay
getting into these bigger festivals and
not going
yeah you get different most I find want
to attend and we're talking pre-covet
again before when you could but um
most I find want to attend occasionally
I'll find someone who doesn't really
care about going
um but overwhelming 90 I think want to
go and have the experience of of the
crowd and and all the things that you
get out of the film festival
yeah sure q a yeah those are great yeah
yeah absolutely right feeling the energy
yeah what red flag should a filmmaker
look for if they are considering hiring
a producer rep
well
um
so I would say
look at all their go to IMDb
look at their history of all the films
that they've sold
um call those filmmakers
um if you know dig in find a website
address you know if it's not rarely
available get to those people and and
call them and see what kind of
experience they had
um
I imagine that all producer reps and
Distributors and sales agents all have
people that don't like them
but hopefully you find someone that's
got more people that like them that
don't like them
um
I think
I I think you know when I when I pitch
myself for and I never really cognizant
of like who else they're looking at like
I don't have a sense of my competition
that way it's never like me against the
same three guys for a film it just
doesn't it's fairly um I find that
I think most films that I talk to about
repping their films
um
aren't really considering many other
options
um that's the sense I get I don't really
ask them about it or really care
um
but um
I could say this so I know when I decide
to get into the business
I was working for an international sales
agent at the time
and looking around the landscape I felt
like there was a need for someone to do
what I do
a little bit more deeply than I felt
like other producer reps were doing it
like I kind of alluded to before there's
a lot of just kind of okay toss it to
the wall if none of these 10
Distributors want it moving on you know
um which leaves everybody empty and and
so I really try to do I I try to do the
job of making sure I understand the full
distribution landscape
who are the best possible options for
this film if none of them want it what
are the possible second
tier options for them to do I also have
my own tricks of the trade if something
were to fall to self-distribution
per se
what's the what are the best practices
there who's the best aggregator to use
you know those situations so I'm I'm
trying to I'm trying to provide a full
kind of Consulting service around what I
do as opposed to that so I I think that
um
when you're looking for a producer rep
it's kind of it's kind of like
references
you know do you like the films they've
sold in the passage your film feel like
a fit
um
you know have they made deals you know
can you can they point to films that
have had deals with Netflix and Hulu and
Showtime and HBO and and IFC Etc
um
but yeah it's funny I should probably
take another look at the at the
landscape of producer reps out there
besides myself and see what options
people have to
to um
maybe give a fuller answer on that but
yeah to a certain degree aging that's
probably the the way to go about it
why is your advice to filmmakers to not
make movies for money well
so it depends on the level of investment
of a film and what you know what my
advice changes film to film for sure and
filmmaker to filmmaker depending on
their goals and what they're doing so
if you want to make if your passion is
to make a film about growing mushrooms
and you want to spend an hour and a half
just watching the mushrooms grow
you know you shouldn't
tell the investor you need 150 000 to
shoot that movie and it'll get on
Netflix for sure right
but if you can go out and do it for your
own pocket change and you can do it on
your iPhone and then you can put it in
an art museum okay great that's your
passion that you had a founder and
interesting way to film those mushrooms
right
um the point there is I guess that
um if you make something low budget and
because it's your and it's your passion
and everybody knows
the high risk of whatever you're
spending
um then great uh everybody's going in
Eyes Wide Open
But ultimately most films just
monetarily fail
overwhelmingly fail
um and that's not because of
Distributors being crooked although
there's a little of that in places
not because they spend too much money
advertising or putting in their pockets
or have exorbitant deals it's because
there's overwhelming amount of content
out there for consumers to consume
and just no way to monetize every
independent film that everybody makes in
in a way that makes sense vis-a-vis the
budget
um
I I'm in the position of seeing the the
results for
you know intimately of over a thousand
films in 25 years
and overwhelmingly the most films fail
that's just that's just the reality
Marketplace if you look at
not to name names but if you look at a
decent Art House distributor
one of the ones that distributes 20 to
25 films a year and has a prominent
brand
um and well thought of and everybody
wants to be with
if you look at their box office for each
of the films that year there are a
couple that get over a million dollars
and there's about 20 that make 200 to a
few thousand dollars and they've spent
money to try to make those films into
something and it just didn't work
right
so
um
that's why everyone should approach
filmmaking as the business with a huge
amount of caution because it's it's
better to put your film in a mutual your
buddy in a future mod sorry your money
in a mutual fund right it's not a film
is not a great investment
um
um and so you know if you are making a
film for in the two to three million
dollar range there are ways to go about
it without just taking someone's cash
and blowing it that to amortize the risk
um or to minimize the risk
um you can shoot in an estate with a tax
credit like to take care of 25 at 30
percent of the budget so narrowing how
much the person has to spend in cash on
the film
there's getting uh involved with a
international sales agent and getting
cast that they can sell the film on to
to pre-sell the film so that you can
take those contracts and Cat and get
cash for those from a bank in order to
squeeze down the amount of equity you
have to spend
so there are ways to minimize it so that
you've let's say you've made a two
million dollar film and you now all you
need in equity is 25 of the budget
you know you're making a two million
dollar film essentially for
uh half a million dollars
now hopefully with the name that you've
got and the quality of the film you made
when you're when it's done you'll be
able to present it to the territories
you did pre-sell and get numbers that
are bigger than that half a million but
you're still risking that half million
dollars
um if it turns out badly it's gone
there's just only so many films a year
that Distributors who can pay a million
dollars plus for a film are gonna buy
um like I said there's like 10 000 films
made a year and you know big you know
the biggest Distributors that actually
take on indie films only won a couple of
them
um you know companies you know a little
a little lower down what 20 25. the ones
are doing you know real theatrical films
a year
um there's some that want 10 to 20.
um and then there are there's a you know
a good number of
I would call kind of mostly all rights
just digital Distributors who sometimes
do theatrical as well but most of them
aren't paying a lot of money for films
so
you know we are looking at the film as a
business you have to realize it's hardly
even a business it's practically
throwing money away
um and the thing that Studios and and
bigger Distributors know is that not
they know all films are not going to
work so they're but they're they're
playing the long game of making multiple
films over the course of a year and that
they know that the winners will pay for
the losers over time as independent
filmmaker one making one movie you're
taking one shot and
um that makes it even a higher risk
so going back to the argument of you
know
[Music]
don't try to make money from the film
this it seems like it's an interesting
thing in that do you make it for the
market and try to try to cash in on it
or do you make it based on something
you're really passionate about but then
is it going to be marketable yeah
that's tough I think you have you have
to look to the individual and their soul
and what they're about at the end of the
day right and
there are some people that how is they
have it all they have the talent they
have something they're very passionate
about that that is let's say it's a
dramatic story that isn't a thriller or
horror or family film it's not obviously
commercial but they've just really
they've written it well people responded
to on the page actors are responding to
on the page financiers are responding on
the page and then it all comes together
and it becomes this great thing that
does well it sells the Netflix or sells
to a big company
um that can happen but those are very
rare occurrences
um
so I think all filmmakers have to kind
of Juggle that stuff some people also
inherently have commercial sensibilities
and they grew up loving
Spielberg and and uh and Ron Howard and
people and who people who had commercial
sensibilities and they tell this kind of
instinctively tell commercial stories
um there's some people that don't they
go you know they're more uh Fellini fans
or truffaut or someone like and that's
what the way they see the world but they
you know
and probably having those influences is
going to make the way they tell stories
a little different
um and so that has to be kind of brought
to the mix of like how old is this how
is this Talent converge with what's
commercial I don't think it's ever
really good
you know to
make a movie because well it's the right
genre and we've got the right name
but the town the director's okay
and the screenplay is okay right that's
you know okay maybe they'll trade
dollars because they could pre-sell the
movie and get some money based on the
name and it gets an okay deal but it's
probably just trading dollars at the end
of the day it's probably not gonna the
film's probably not gonna lift beyond
that
I think there you have to take into
consideration kind of everything
um in this business when you're making a
film again depending on the budget again
if you're going out and spending ten
thousand dollars
on your little movie
go crazy right like you're you're only
risking your own ten thousand dollars
um and there are there are lots of
people doing that and that's that's fine
right as long as you understand that
like you're probably not getting a
hundred thousand dollar HBO deal out of
that
so cursed are the ones that want to do a
movie on shiitake mushrooms
with Organic Soil and and but you never
know if it's just the greatest mushroom
yeah only cursed if they think that
they're
they're gonna get a Netflix deal out of
it right okay if it's if it's okay that
they make it and show it in an art
museum perfectly legitimate right
there's an audience there there are
people that like avant-garde interesting
experimental things
but you don't see that stuff on the
major streamers You Don't See
you know even you know IFC Magnolia a24
they're not picking up
you know avant-garde stuff or just even
or weird stuff I mean if you look at
most their slates it's fairly commercial
stuff even though it's you know you know
high brow and has interesting filmmakers
a lot of them you know you look at genre
you know a lot a lot of those films are
Thrillers and horror films they're just
elevated in some way right a good
portion of them
um none of those guys are doing like you
know 25 dramas a year
um the market wouldn't bear it for them
it wouldn't work
yeah I don't know why this keeps coming
into my my mind right now but Searching
for Sugar Man which was such an
excellent film I know some people were
critical of it I loved it but it was
able to sort of transcend I mean it it
won an Academy Award correct or yeah I
think so yeah yeah and and so here
here's a story that seems kind of
unlikely
and it was just so beautifully told and
the the main character yeah so
fascinating and there are anomalies
right so this is like but you just don't
build a business which is each film is
almost a business at a certain budget
level right
um you can't you can't build a business
based on an anomaly right you have to
you should you should look at genre you
should look at cast you should look at
those things depending on what your
budget level is
um there's certain budget levels you
can't afford cast right you can't afford
names that will work on your film
um you know unless you're
uncle is Tom Cruise you know like then
then you know you're you're most likely
not casting someone that that helps prop
up the movie
so um I think
you have to factor in cast and genre in
your budget
you know in addition something I don't
think enough people do is vet their
screenplay you know with
get 100 people to read it you know get
script services to read it get feedback
um there's so many so many films that I
have to turn down that I think wow is
really well shot and
and the acting's competent but there's
just no story here or there's just not
enough of the story or I didn't get the
story fast enough you know there's
certain kind of rules of screenwriting
you know you kind of have to follow in
order to make a you know a commercial
movie
this is a hard topic for us to bring up
but I'm hoping maybe you can clear up
some misconceptions
we often hear that filmmakers aren't
making money from distribution deals but
at the same time we hear that you can
make great money working in distribution
can you can you help us understand here
well yes
um
so in my opinion
most people aren't making money from
distribution because most films just
don't work because the public didn't
decide to click on your movie they
didn't buy a ticket
um there's just a lot more
um there's just a lot more content being
created by
the streamers and by Studios that and
and we've got other ways of entertaining
ourselves in movies these days games and
Tick Tock and whatever that is there's
just not a lot of as much demand as
there's not a lot of demand compared to
the supply at the end of the day
and so I find that
um
and distributors
are in the job of taking a certain a
certain number of films a year
they know that some are going to work
they know by experience not all of them
are going to work and they're going to
do about the same thing on every film
maybe treating one a little better a
little bit more p a uh you know more
advertising dollars behind it in order
to make it work
and
and they're good so they're gonna take
each one out and if one doesn't work
it's going to then go through the
motions of trying to get a team you know
if it didn't work in Theatrical and or
transactional VOD like iTunes and Amazon
where people can rent and buy it it
didn't work there they're still going to
try to sell it to HBO or Hulu if they
can if it doesn't work there then
they're going to put it on Advertising
video man demand channels like two beer
Pluto that pay small royalties per view
right and that's what most that's the
windowing that most Distributors do
and there's not a lot to that right it's
just placement at the salesmanship and
placement and they're not going to spit
like if a film didn't work in the very
beginning they're not going to keep
spending advertising dollars they're
going to keep there's not much for them
to do
and I think filmmakers
feel like
you know hey you're not doing anything
for my movie well but should they be
doing anything for your movie if they
did more for your movie they would
probably lose more money
if the film didn't work on the outset if
it didn't connect in the first three
months of its life it's it's
not going to make money and that's and
it's going to stay with that distributor
as they're going to put it through the
platforms properly but if they were to
spend more time and effort trying to
monetize it they would lose
and you wouldn't make any more money is
the reality
um in addition
I think in general Distributors are
pretty bad at communicating that
two filmmakers I constantly am having to
preach that on their behalf
to my clients and other people in the
business because
um
all I've gone on to
um there's platforms out there where
people vent about distribution right and
you know I see who they're who they're
venting about
and I know the I know and some yes there
are some there there are some scumbags
out there that no one should ever go
near
but there are some people they're
venting about on there that I know are
running honest businesses
and doing it properly but they're just
not going to
be your best friend forever right
they're not gonna be the best friend of
the film forever they're just gonna do
their job if it works great if it
doesn't it doesn't I also find some some
filmmakers just don't understand their
contracts when they get into them
um
you know there are some Distributors of
a certain level that are saying okay
we're gonna put the film out
theatrically we're going to spend this
amount of money and here's a big check
and that's that's great you know forget
about that for a second but most deals
are with Distributors that are not
putting up any money
and just going to take it out on the
various digital platforms and try to
sell off Netflix and Hulu later Etc
um and in those cases many filmmakers
just don't understand that that's what
they're getting into they think I got a
distributor my life is saved my film is
going to make a lot of money and they're
going to Market it without even talking
to them about marketing and sometimes
these countries even literally say we're
not hiring a publicist we're not
marketing the film we have the option to
but we're not pledging to
and so if you go in thinking you're
going to do one thing and they don't do
it then there's then you're getting on
you know some platform and saying oh I
hate so and so you know
um and so that's why I I see a lot of
that that's not to diminish the people
that do get screwed over there are there
are companies there are Bad actors out
there but there are
um a lot of Distributors that just I
think a are doing the job properly if if
even if they are falling a little short
on the communication of why the films
are not working to their clients
so it's kind of a barring someone being
dishonest if a company is honest but but
then you have a filmmaker a over here
who feels like I'm not being given
attention and my movie's just being
shoved to the back it sounds like
there's just the communication is just
really broken and one is a business
person the other is kind of an artist
that's very possessive over their their
work yeah and they're not meeting in the
middle yeah I think that's right and I
think and that's not to say I wish that
Distributors could be a little bit more
communicative and a little bit more in
kind of in general even the ones I like
um could be a little bit more
um
um responsive to phone calls and emails
from clients but
um I think to a certain degree
a lot of these companies are taking a
lot of films and they've got to kind of
move on to the things that work and
not all filmmakers are are personable
nice people either
right you get some
filmmakers that have screws loose or are
have Napoleonic complexes or whatever
they have and
um and and they're coming after them
with phone call after phone call day
after day as a distributor like do I
have to deal with that or I don't I
don't have a contractual obligation to
call back a jerk
right I'm going to move on and start
working I'm working just like I do any
other film whether he's a jerk or not
I'm going to do the same thing right I'm
just going to stop talking to him
because he's just wasting my time right
now most filmmakers aren't like that but
there are that does happen and I think
that because that happens that it also
makes distributors
you know a little bit more reticent to
be personable and and and and and
communicate with their filmmakers in
case it turns into that kind of like
like why am I on this conversation with
this person who
I I put their film out it's not making
me any more money to talk to them about
what's happening yes they're my client
but
um what you know what is there to do at
this point and the reality too is
hard about this too is that some of
these contracts are seven ten years long
right and so filmmakers quite often feel
stuck they're like they're not doing
anything with my movie and I can't get
it back
well the problem there is what do you do
when you get it back
you knocking no other distributor is
going to take it after it's been
distributed by somebody else
you're not going to be able to get
Netflix or Hulu or so so and so to look
at it most likely they've already shown
it to them and they've passed
um if you get it back if they do agree
if they do agree to give it back to you
have to get extracted from all these
digital platforms that it's on they
can't just turn the hose over to you and
have the financials just start go you
have to pull it off
and then you have a hard time getting it
back on because some of those some of
those platforms are like we've had this
film before it acts like like you know
we don't want old films
[Music]
um
and so it's you know and so people end
up putting on Amazon Prime or you know
to kind of direct themselves and it just
sits there and doesn't make any money
anyway
so most filmmakers should be if they can
moving on to the next thing at that
point what's my next project how can I
take whatever Happened Here make some
good out of it and hype it towards
getting my next thing done because once
you've got once you've made that
distribution deal whether you're in a
good situation or a bad situation
you're that's it that's your your film
is is that's going to be the story of
your film one way or the other
um yeah it's kind of an illusion that
you can get it back at some point and
and make something out of it and that's
why
in addition to knowing who the buyers
are and being able to read and
understand contracts isn't that's kind
of where I come in I know
who communicates well I know who does
the job properly and what that job
actually is as opposed to what it is and
can explain that to the filmmakers so
they know what they're getting into when
we make the deal so we don't get those
calls two years later saying
you know why aren't they marketing my
film because they knew about going in
because I explained it to them exactly
what kind of situation they got
well you use the word illusion which I
thought's fitting because maybe they did
read the contract maybe you explained
that to them properly but there's an
illusion mine's going to be different I
realize it's going to be locked up for
the but this is different yeah and
there's nothing against the filmmaker
it's just we all think our thing is 100
I've I've produced movies as well with
other you know not myself alone but with
other people and
um
and I've I've gotten the spell I've been
in the bubble of like we made the
greatest thing ever you know this is
going to go to whoever and
um so I unders I do understand that and
I do have and I do have clients that
despite I explain it to them do come
back to me later and say like why aren't
they doing this and like well if you
remember this is what we talked about
you know it's not quite like that for
this film
should a filmmaker kind of take the
worst case scenario I know some people
don't like to operate like that but it
can help if you kind of take the worst
case scenario
stance you know you're looking at the
contract and thinking well I know it
says I'll be locked up in this territory
whatever for seven years but I'm sure
it'll be fine and maybe just have
something in their mind do I really want
that
is this really for me
um
I think that yes I think that
I think you can make an educated guess
on what the worst case will be based on
the habits of the company you're in bed
with to a certain degree
so because you know most distribution
agreements don't have anything in them
that says they have to put out the movie
either
right
sometimes we can build in Clauses where
it says if you don't release it in nine
months we'll get the movie back
but that's pretty easy to fulfill I can
throw it on Amazon and it's released per
se right so it's hard to get a
distribute like a narrow get a
distributed guarantee what will happen
I'm saying that because if you are
if you do get a deal with a distributor
and you look back on the last couple of
years and you see oh they've released
all these films and these this is how
they've released them there's a little
more security that the worst case
scenario is that they're going to
release it like that
right they said they're going to put it
on all these platforms they did it for
all these other films so that's most
likely the worst case scenario and the
worst case scenario is that
they do that and no one bothers to buy
the movie
you know that can happen for you know
lots of films
um
you know it doesn't happen at a certain
level if you're getting big theatrical
deals but we're talking about straight
to digital you know distribution that's
very much but it's it's funny because
I've had
so many films now go to these
Distributors that handle all rights
and give them the same treatment
and some make a couple hundred thousand
dollars and some make two thousand
dollars
and you really can't
see any difference between the two
except that perhaps the artwork just
clicked with the public better the
trailer clicked someone said something
about it kind of organically online and
that took off and created a swirl it's
really hard like there's a lot of things
you can tell a filmmaker to try to do to
support a film publicity get in a social
media company
um doing a theatrical there's nothing
that guarantees that any of that will
help or work
um almost always do kind of if someone
just has has a a digital distribution
deal say try to do something to help
support it because at least you feel
like you did something
um but there's no real empirical
evidence that like having a publicist
for a film makes a dollar more
um or that running five thousand dollars
in social media ads makes ten dollars
more
um at least from what I see in terms of
looking at films I've seen many films
get no treatment make lots of money and
some don't
we posted a poll on our YouTube
Community Tab and the question was do
you trust film Distributors so the poll
received about 8 000 or so votes and 85
percent of those polled said they do not
trust Distributors oh now we didn't ask
them in what capacity they've dealt with
them where do you think this negative
reputation stems from
it all goes to the the failure rate of
films and I think that
um I think some Distributors oversell
what will happen
to films in order to get them
um not all but some do
um
I think it goes to expectations of just
getting a distribution deal and thinking
hey I'm done it's going to make make
money I think that's part of it
um
I think it's frustrating to have
Gatekeepers
to the public you know there's there
there are so many things coming out of a
dollar before it gets to you
um as the filmmaker because you know
someone buys the film on iTunes
um iTunes is taking 30 percent
all right that's 70 is going to your
distributor your distributor is taking
and costs so when they get by costs then
they're paying you at that point right
so there's there's a lot of
international sales
your International sales companies
taking 20 percent they're putting it
with a distributor overseas is going to
take their percentage that distributor
is putting on a digital platform that's
going to put it and make money in
Germany or wherever so there's three
steps before it gets gets to you
um
so you know if it were the case that and
is the case that you know people could
go and put film you do have the ability
to go put the film on digital platforms
yourself
so
um there are Labs that have kind of
aggregator
um kind of call themselves aggregators
although I think the word aggregator is
kind of a strange word for it but all
they're really doing is facilitating
placing the film on Amazon iTunes Google
Play
Etc
um and they're you're paying them the
cost of encoding the phone for the
platform
but they're not taking a percentage at
all so you're you know iTunes is taking
30 and you're getting 70 percent
um
the reason
why and now maybe some films should do
that because
they could just you know it's a small
film and they can push people to watch
on iTunes and then they get what they
they reap what they sow
um the reason people go to Distributors
as opposed to doing it themselves is
Distributors can get to more platforms
than these Labs can
there are some platforms that require a
pitch
so to get a film on
in demand DirecTV dish
Etc you need someone to go and Pitch the
movie to them
and then when it comes out on iTunes and
Amazon Etc it's going to be the release
date is going to be the same for those
platforms
um in addition
these Distributors have relationships
with streaming companies like Netflix
and Hulu and HBO so once they have the
film in the transactional VOD world
they're then going to go try to make
that sell if you go put your phone on
iTunes you can't there's no way to get
into Netflix at that point even I can't
go to Netflix I I can go to Netflix
originals division as a producer rep but
I can't go to them in a distributor
position of where it is after it's been
on transactional for a while
so
if we lived in a world where all these
platforms were open to filmmakers going
there that's what we would do
and I would I would become a marketing
expert instead I would help people with
marketing and just say hey let's just go
put in these platforms
but there are Gatekeepers to those
platforms or people have those
relationships and that's the reason we
have to use them
um and then there are some people that
um treat that space
honorably and understand you know uh
are respectful of the fact they got
lucky enough to be in such a position to
be the Gateway for other people's
content and treat their filmmakers well
and explain everything to them and try
to do the best and then there are some
that
really just take it and never call you
back and that's that's for you know I
think it kind of goes back to
communication I think at the end of the
day there's just if if Distributors did
a better job of communicating
on the front end
what's going to happen what the what you
know what's likely
what's you know realistically the a
medium outcome or the best outcome
um and in addition
we're a little bit more open as
filmmakers came back to them with
questions about how it's going
and explain what you know why they were
doing what they were doing I think if
they were better at that in general that
poll number would be a little bit better
um
although I think the the main reason for
it is just most films fail and and
therefore who we're going to blame I'm
not gonna blame my movie my movie is
perfect right like I it's my baby
um and the person who adopted my baby is
not raising it properly you know
um
and uh
but um
but yeah I think um
but that's hard that's hard for them to
do it's you know it's and then you're
dealing with corporations
and Distributors are not individuals
and so you've got you know the director
of Acquisitions the director of sales
the director of delivery the CFO the
accounting department
and they all have their own Lanes of
what they kind of deal with and as the
filmmaker like oh so who do I talk to
about the fact that this doesn't look
right or I want I don't you know Amazon
my poster on Amazon looks a little weird
or whatever and sometimes it's hard to
navigate because not all companies have
a front person that's just like you know
kind of the the go-to for the client to
say okay you got this problem you know
talk to this person
um I think part of this is like
economics like they just don't have the
bandwidth to have that many employees at
the end of the day and take the you know
they they do the math of like we need to
take this number of films we can make
this amount of money and so we've got a
you know stretch our employees to do
this number of jobs they're just not
going to get
Royal Treatment like they want
and then there's also the the sort of
thought of that you know filmmakers or
artists and their work is kind of never
done so they're probably tweaking the
poster art maybe the log line different
things and then they're making all these
changes and submitting it and then
you're dealing with business people who
don't have the time maybe to to hand
hold
all these subsequentions you know I mean
I'm sure that probably happens a little
bit and then they feel like they're
being ignored and maybe in some cases
they are being ignored and others it's
just their demands are so high
yeah
um
yeah I don't know if I I don't see a lot
of people still tinkering after the fact
it's usually
the T It's usually the case that they
have to at some point they have to you
know okay I'm done and let it and let it
go creatively at least in terms of log
line or trailer or things like that I
don't see a lot of people where I see it
breaking down is much more in terms of
like well what's happening
you're like are you trying to sell
Netflix
like I haven't heard
um anything and most Distributors just
don't care about communicating that the
They Don't Really they feel like you
know we're doing our job we're going to
pay you
what you do but we don't need to explain
to you what we're saying to Netflix or
when we're going to talk to Netflix
or or any of that
um
I just feel like
Distributors probably
don't feel like they have the time
in a day to talk to all their filmmakers
about all the intricacies of everything
they do
is my best guess
best guess from being on the outside
looking in a lot but never really been
in
at the same time
what type of accounting practices should
a filmmaker expect when working with a
distributor so overwhelmingly most
Distributors offer quarterly accountings
um and that's that's pretty standard to
at least get two or three years of
quarterly and then
um
and then turns the biannual after that
or annual sometimes
um and that's when your most of your
revenue is gonna that's what it really
counts the most
um the frustrating thing with accounting
is that Distributors are on accounting
terms as well with the platforms
so a lot of times people get their first
quarter statement and they're rated you
know okay let's see how we did and it's
not there's not much there
and that's partly because
when I go and buy a film on Amazon
keeps that money for 90 days
before it hits the bank account of your
distributor
and so
if it's March and I paid for uh in March
um it's not going to hit
um
uh the distributor until June
and that's the second quarter so even
though someone paid for something in the
first quarter
the distributor didn't get it until the
second quarter and so that's when
they're going to account for it usually
anywhere from 30 to 90 days after the
quarter
so it takes a long time for stuff to
come in
and that's frustrating I wish it was
more
I wish it was unfortunately
that's what makes it hard to do anything
in social media to try to help the cause
because you can if you buy ads and stuff
for lots of products out there you can
kind of see what it does for you right
and if you spend you know ten thousand
dollars on Facebook ads you can see what
the return is on whatever you're selling
pretty quickly because you're the one
selling it
but in film you you do the advertisement
and you're waiting
uh six months to find out whether Amazon
anybody bought the film on Amazon and
then your past really the period so
that's makes the whole business so hard
because you just don't the companies
that dominate the space in terms of
where people buy movies
um Can can dictate the terms of how they
account
even to the distributors
so you're saying that a filmmaker
reasonably most contracts would say
every quarter you're getting a statement
for two years and then after that it's
biannually and then annually yeah okay
so then if they have nine years then
toward the latter end of it they're
going to be getting yearly statements
correct
and some it depends on the distributor
because some distributors
are more amenable to changing their
basic terms than others so it kind of
depends but
um some Distributors will say well
eventually if we if we don't collect
anything we're not going to account
so there's zero coming in there's no
reason to send you a piece of paper that
says zero came in
um sometimes we try to add language that
says you're going to count to this
regardless because I want you to be
accountable per se
um so it yeah can depend on the
distributor
just as a film's budget impact what
it'll sell for let's say someone makes a
film for half a million is a distributor
likely to make an offer of half a
million no
um
in fact they don't care what the budget
is they may care from the point of view
of Interest like oh how you know if
they're
um know anything about production and
they think oh wow you really this looks
great what did you spend from that
perspective
the distributors in general they want to
all they care about is what it's worth
on the market
and they're going to look at your film
and compare it to other films in their
catalog or in their imagination or
wherever they however they make their
subjective evaluation of your film and
decide okay we think once it goes out
into the world it'll make
um we think it will make a million
dollars
then they might be advancing and they
really have to think it it's going to
make a million dollars in order to
advance half a million dollars
um because there's still gonna be costs
for them to
especially if there's if there's if
they're if they're buying something for
half a million dollars
uh their price you know spending a
couple million dollars to monetize
that thing they can't just you buy
something for half a million dollars you
can't just put it on the
um on transactional VOD and hope to sell
it later
um films don't make that much money when
you do that
um
so it's it's all about what what how
much revenue do we feel like this can
make for us or how many viewers do we
feel like or how many subscribers are we
going to gain because of this
this title that's the way you know
Netflix and Hulu and people like that
look at it
um
because at the end of the day
um I've seen half a million dollars
films that look like they were made for
two dollars I've seen half a million
dollars films that look like they were
made for seven million dollars
so that goes to the talent of the
production company and the filmmaker and
the ability to you know get value from
what they spent
why do we hear that it's bad for
filmmakers to be transparent about their
budget
so with regard to being transparent to a
distributor
um
I think that you know if it's because it
could go you they could go badly two
different ways if I tell a distributor I
made it for half a million dollars their
opinion would be like wow
that was ridiculous like why did you
spend so much money
um and then make them make them afraid
of making an offer because if you're
expecting to make
that much money back they may not feel
like you even even though they're maybe
the best option for you they may feel
conservatively that they're not going to
make that much money for you
um
you know on the flip side
if they're if they're wowed by it it
doesn't I don't think it really makes
much difference from them unless they're
the kind of company that
um
is in the business of making films
themselves
and are looking at you as a potential
filmmaker to invest in in the future and
there are very few Distributors actually
most distributors
um don't do that most servers are just
Distributors and so they don't really
you know the budget just doesn't really
matter to them but it might matter to
some some Distributors that um
that actually make movies
well it's interesting because it seems
like with Hollywood we know their budget
and it's out there in the trades whereas
with independent filmmakers we're almost
supposed to hide ours like in a shameful
way
yeah
um I I usually just take the I take the
position of not being hiding it for
shame I just like why does it make any
difference
right like
um unless you
made it for ten thousand dollars and it
looks like half a million and you want
to brag about it and make that kind of
part of your
your pitch that look how great we are we
could make something short but not I
don't find most Hollywood cares about
that
or and I think that story's been played
right we had Robert Rodriguez and a
couple of others that have like wow this
film was made for nothing
um and now people tons of people make
films for nothing every day someone made
a film for almost nothing so it's no
longer really a badge of honor
um it's just another fact
um and not a very sexy one
way or the other I don't think
so I tend to sell people that's just not
they're not going to ask us
so let's not put it out there this is
the way the way I see it I think it's
irrelevant like look at the quality of
the film if you want it pay the right
price for it
but why is it different for Hollywood
why are we okay knowing
the you know this many million was spent
on this film
well there again I'm not depending on
the Hollywood film because there's
different there's Studio level and then
there's things that are kind of made
with International sales agents that pop
up to Studio level and so there's
different kinds of Studio films
um I'm not sure we're getting the
accurate budget from
from these people even though they're
public
um sometimes so
um I think there's also
there's been a number of times and you
know the number got out that a
production spent and it was so much that
it had a negative impact on people
viewing the film
um probably would have failed anyway but
there's a few out there that spent 200
million and be you know people were like
wow that that they shouldn't have done
that all right so
um yeah mishtar Johnny Depp Native
American Film played Tonto oh uh Lone
Ranger you know there are a few examples
out there of how it negatively impacted
the the publicity so
um
I think some of the some of the numbers
you see about Hollywood production stuff
out there is guessing really guesswork
and some ins getting some in-flight
information but that they're not
necessarily publishing every budget for
everybody to see I don't think that's
that's really happening
can you give us the ranges of how much
movies make on various platforms
well I can tell you from kind of a true
Indie perspective right
um because I work on a mostly true indie
films not made in Hollywood not made
with International sales agents not made
with Kevin Bacon in it you know those
are the films I mostly work on
um
and I see
um the range of Revenue coming off of
transactional VOD
um which is rental and buying on iTunes
and Amazon and the various cable TV
platforms
um straight to digital no theatrical the
range is kind of zero you know almost
zero to
150 000
about in that range with the median
being much closer to zero and the
outliers
at the 150 range so it's not like the
average is 75.
the average is the media the median is
more like
um 20 000 I'd say 30 000 for most most
films and sorry to interrupt this is for
the life of the term of the contract
correct okay
and most of that Revenue coming in
within the first two years and then just
dropping
um
the next window they go to then of
course is s voter TV sales and the range
there is
not making that deal so there's zero
coming in off of that window
to a couple hundred thousand dollars
with most films not getting that deal
that's probably the most likely case to
some films getting 40 to 20 to 60 in
that range
and then avod is a growing uh sorry
advertising video on demand which is to
be in Pluto where they're paying royalty
people are watching
um because uh and watching advertisement
rather than subscribing or paying for it
um those platforms are paying 10 to 15
cents per view
and the revenues on there are
um again kind of zero to 150
000 in that range as well
and growing because it's it's a growing
um part of the business because a lot of
people don't want to pay there's a lot
of people who don't have money to
subscribe to 10 platforms
um let alone one
and don't want to rent movies but watch
a lot of stuff in that in that in that
ecosystem now so it's a growing Growing
Place for films to make money and you
can't skip Those ads correct they're not
skipping that's right that's right and
they come up in weird
awful places right as well it's not the
best view to experience and you said 15
cents per is it per view it's purview
what if they if they watch a decent
amount of the film I think it's if they
watch most of the movie then the royalty
paid out is can be 15 cents per view
um
which is a lot better than what Amazon
Prime went down to which is one cent per
view
um so that's been uh but we don't know
where that's going to go because there
are more there are many more avod
platforms out there lots of Distributors
are creating their own avod platforms
advertising video on demand platforms
um
and um
and uh
you know it just depends the 2B was
bought by Fox
um and the way these things go you just
never know what they're going to do with
the platform do they keep it being a
place where Distributors can put all
their stuff or do they eventually turn
into something else like Netflix at one
point was the place where you watched
all the movies you ever could right like
it had every movie now you go to watch
Netflix content on Netflix
um mostly so
so we'll see is that purview per like IP
address if the same user is watching
things over and over again it can still
generate money yeah I'm not sure about
that I'm I imagine that the system
probably has
safeguards against people creating
algorithms so that they just can just
like play a film over and over again and
make it money right I'm sure that they
have safeguards against that but I don't
know for sure
when you're reviewing a movie that a
potential client has sent you are you
watching the whole movie
yeah if I
unless I
it isn't very good
yeah so you have a limit yo yeah oh yeah
um
yeah if I if I enjoy it I I watch it
um all the way through and
um and then if I if I'm hired I usually
watch it again before I start talking
about it
um because usually there's a few weeks
between that moment and when I actually
start doing it so I'm usually watching
my films twice
um
and um
but yeah I think that's you know there
are a lot of films though where you just
kind of like I can't sell it you know
like why why why you know you know
within 10 minutes there are lots of out
of focus stuff for the acting's really
bad or there's a lot of bad movies
um out there that no one ever sees
that uh that I I get to watch a little
bit of
that was my next question yeah what
would make you turn it off after I we
have five minutes but okay let's say 10
minutes so you give it do you have a
rule like I'll give it a certain amount
of time and then yeah it's it's more
instinctive it's a more
um
it's um
I I don't I don't think anybody out of
the circle of friends of the person who
made the movie would doubt why I got out
like it's that you know there's a lot of
um well I should say though there's also
stuff I just don't think there's a home
for
and if it's like
um you know the hardest category is is
drama without names
um and if you found an interesting way
to tell the story then
then and it works and we think there's a
home for it then great but
um that I find is probably the hardest
to pull off and if if you haven't like
grabbed me in the first 10 minutes
you're probably not a grab you know
distributor who has less patience than
me
um and so I probably can't help you you
know but I think I I mean I think I
probably
that's for some films but there are some
films I watch all the way through and
then make that same decision that like
well I got there but it was torturous
right like her or in some way I just
couldn't I just don't feel like I could
help them
and what do you tell filmmakers that
fall into that category
the truth
yeah you know I
um without being mean about it you know
with just saying hey I thank you for
sharing the movie
um it's not it's not right for me
um I just don't feel like I could sell
it and maybe there's someone out there
for you and here maybe give them some
other people
um that you know there's a there's a
website out there with a bunch of
producer reps on it and I usually say
you know check out that and maybe
there's another way for you or in some
some people are also very nice it also
especially if they're very nice people
and they made a bad movie that's really
hard and so I'll even get on the phone
with them and talk to them about
self-distribution and what they maybe
could do you know themselves that might
be the best option because I don't think
that there's a distributor would take it
on so I'll have that conversation with
people
um once in a while
are there individuals who will fight you
on it and say you didn't give it a
chance or they'll kind of like negate
your issues that you have with it yeah
but not often
yeah there have been
get all types of people
for sure I've had some movies I've
watched you know a couple movies because
I've watched thousands of movies
um
a couple movies where I watched the film
and I really wondered about the sanity
of the person who made the movie
not a good way like a razor head or
something like that but in a really
disturbing like what is this weird thing
that someone sent me and I don't want to
talk to them at all that's happened a
couple times but that's pretty you know
and I've had a couple you know I've had
a few people who are like
um who make the pitch that like you know
this is better you think I'm like well
then I'm sure you'll find a home
is it hard for you to tell people no
no
I am
it's part of the job I think I think
it's to be honest and
um my mission in general is to help
filmmakers
um
get the best possible distribution
and if I extend that to everyone even to
not my clients
um and the best message for them is you
should distribute this yourself because
I don't think a distributor will take it
on I think if
I've got an obligation to share that
message and
it's much it's actually easier than
than saying oh it's really good but I
can I don't know how to make stuff up I
don't know I wouldn't know how to how to
how to fake that well in some ways you
might be helping them because then if
they're getting the same notes then if
they make another project they'll try to
correct right yeah yeah 100 percent
would you rather a filmmaker send you
their trailer or the entire film
um the whole film I like to see the
whole thing
um
usually
almost I don't know if I've ever turned
a film down off of a trailer
I don't think I have and quite often
people will send me a trailer
when they when they reach out to me
um and then I'll say hey looks good can
I see the whole movie but I almost like
to see the whole thing before I talk to
someone as well so I get a feeling for
what they have sometimes people want to
talk ahead of time and I just feel it's
a bit of a waste of time because
yeah I don't know if I know if I can
help you yet I don't know what to tell
you yet
and then it becomes just a free tutorial
you know like about the business where I
don't mind that but I prefer to be
afterwards let's do it in one shot
rather than several so
do you have a preferred method for for
watching something or do you have it
just playing on another screen
um I throw up I've uh I most people send
vimeulinks and I usually throw them up
on my big screen TV to watch them
um I have a little quirk in that I like
to
um
when I go to buyers with films
um if we're not pushing them to a
theater it's it's South by Southwest or
um
if we're just sharing it with them
directly there are some Distributors I
like to uh to send a Blu-ray as opposed
to a female link
um
not all of them will do it some would
prefer to give me a link but there are
some that are open to getting my Blu-ray
and then I prefer that a little bit
because I'm forcing them to watch it on
something bigger than than
um than their phone because I know some
of them do I haven't seen it personally
that someone watched it on their phone
but given that you can I imagine that
like you know if you're an Acquisitions
executive and you've got five films to
watch that day and you're at lunch you
might pop one on your phone
um just to get just to get through it
um and then you know it's not that's not
the most illegitimate thing to do given
that if you're a straight to digital
Distributors lots of people watching
these things on small screens
um so they may feel like they can but I
just feel like in general if I'm trying
to like
get someone to take on a movie I'm
usually trying to encourage them to
watch on something bigger
just so they have a better experience
than than something like an iPad you
know
you mentioned that you occasionally will
watch a string of bad movies here and
there how many movies do you feel like
you have to go through to get to one
that really piques your interest
it's probably well first of all I the
number of clients come to me from
referrals
either from agencies because they think
hey it's too small for for us and they
recommend me
and they usually don't recommend me
unless it's someone they think there's a
possibility of me taking it on
um I get referrals from from just kind
of being out there in the world for a
long time
um
and so the referral the the
the
um the rate of which I take films on for
referrals is quite High
um because those have been curated to a
certain degree
um
and there's
but from the the cold ones the ones that
come in cold to me I probably have to
watch 10 to find one
that I feel like I can work on
um
it's about that ratio
how do you handle it when a producer
comes to you and they expect to make
let's say a million dollars off a film
with a half a million dollar budget
so I'm always measuring expectations
with
potential clients
um because
um
I don't really want to work with someone
that that expects something that's not
going to happen
um
especially if they're gonna
blame me for it after the fact right
like hey I you I told you I needed to
get a million dollars and you didn't get
a million dollars
um so I'm always very careful to kind of
explain
how much films in general make in the
marketplace what the percentage chances
are for getting a deal with a streamer
what the percentage chances are for
getting with one of these all rights
Distributors and what they do
and then even once you get that deal
because there's a it's never 100 because
it's subjective and we don't know
um
then you know what here's the range of
Revenue you could potentially get and
they have to be comfortable with that
um
because I'm gonna I'm gonna tell them
what the range of Revenue is and so
usually
um there have been cases where it got
past me and I didn't like somehow we
didn't communicate about the number that
they thought they were going to get and
then after the fact they're like I
thought this would make this and I'm
like I don't know how you would have
thought that we went through all this
you know discussion about why that's not
possible
um
and like you said some people just
Harbor that thing in the back of my wall
of mine will be different I don't care
what he's saying and he's still going to
do a good job and still make me money
um but then it you know but I try not to
get into situations
is there a litmus test that you have for
expectations or you can just try to be
as clear as you can you have your own
contracts you have emails
and yeah I mean usually I run a mask in
them where they you know what their
goals are and what their but you know
what their hopes are
um I'd say most people come off with
pre-reasonable hopes it's pretty unusual
for someone to be pretty you know like
oh this is for Netflix and just be no
and just knowing that and being totally
wrong
um that's unusual most people have
I find a certain level of Education of
the business that they know that it's
not you know they know what it is to a
certain degree
um
so I'm helped a little bit by that but
you know I definitely that's part of the
conversation every single time
um if I make it a part of the
conversation it's part of what I when I
when we're emailing back and forth to
start that's part of my questionnaire is
like what you know what are your
expectations what do you hope for or
just also usually ask are there any
disturbers you don't like
um to get out from them the prejudices
that they might have from the the the
um from the internet and you know but
they've heard other Distributors being
bashed on and what they think so I can
dispel those myths to a certain degree
as well
um but yeah those
yeah I have to you know I have to feel
like the client isn't crazy and I have
to feel like they've got
hopes but reasonable expectations at the
same time
I like that so you have a questionnaire
what like 20 questions not even not even
like five questions oh I see okay a lot
of there's more things come out of that
but yes the basic ones are
um what are your expectations for the
film what are the Distributors you don't
you're specifically hoping for are there
any Distributors you particularly don't
want to be with
um what are you what are your Festival
aspirations those are the main ones
has there ever been a situation where
we absolutely love the film but you've
decided not to take it on no
um if I love a film I want to take it on
period even if I think it's going to be
hard
um
as long as
even if I think it's not likely to get
distribution
as long as the filmmaker understands
that it's not likely to get distribution
and I'm going to work as hard as I can
to get a distribution
that being said I don't come across any
films that I don't think can get a
certain level of distribution
like for me like I really don't work on
Films unless
it's gonna get a deal with an all-rise
distributor that will do it properly and
get it on the various digital platforms
I may love it and hope that it gets
better than that and the theatrical or a
Netflix deal you know something bigger
but not think it's gonna but the odds
are against it
um but I just need the filmmaker to be
clear about
that but if I think a film isn't going
to get
it's just I don't know they've ever seen
a film that I loved
that I didn't think would get at least
that level of distribution
I don't think that's happened
how many films have you helped get onto
Netflix
I believe it's five to date most of my
films that have gone on the Netflix have
gone through Distributors who then got
into Netflix but in terms of directly I
believe it's five
how about this year I know we're early
in the oh yeah none this year none this
year okay okay what's the most recent
film you got onto Netflix most recent
trying to think if there's something
after Tinker that got on the Netflix
there's a phone call a kind of Lo-Fi uh
sci-fi film called tinker
I believe that was the last one
so the one where she was a personal
assistant to an insane writer oh okay
because that looked good no Chase
Crawford who's in it okay what are the
advantages of a filmmaker getting their
movie on Netflix
um
several things
you know if first of all if you're
beloved by Netflix and they want to
bring you into the fold in terms of
making films
um you know one of the few companies
that can just you know
say yes very quickly and finance your
your movie
um there's a lot of things that come
with that but you know they're they're
definitely you know they've got a lot of
money to spend on production
um
you know the bragging rights are pretty
huge
um I think that's what you know film and
it's it's a way some people can see
movies very easily everybody doesn't
mind paying the subscription fee no one
has to get out their wallet and pay rent
it for four dollars
um so you can
tell the world about it and everybody
can watch it you know fairly easily
um so I think that's probably the two
main reasons that filmmakers want to be
on Netflix
did they have would you say their their
recommendations
are are one of the best in terms of you
know giving you similar titles
so that your movie will be seen
you know by other movie you know like if
I'm clicking on one then it's just it's
it's so well sort of the algorithm is so
personalized yeah
um yeah I've seen I you know I think
that
um
I I don't think I've ever so my films
have been very indie
and and not Netflix or you know uh
produced
and so I think they're hard they're hard
to find unless you're told about it
at the end of the day
um and perhaps like with in the case of
Tinker if you're uh you love indie film
and and sci-fi
um I'm not I'm not sure even with all
the content they have now if you which
if that film would show up unless you
typed it in and found it that way so
I think it's still hard even to get
visibility on Netflix
um with an indie unless you're you know
something of theirs that got a lot more
promotion than something they acquired
from a distributor
you think that was probably much
different a few years back before they
started producing their own content oh
yeah
yeah at least not to produce movies so
they you know the everything was
um
other people's content Studio content
Disney movies
um
unless yeah unless um and and no Netflix
originals you know at first so yeah
definitely a lot easier
any disadvantages
being on Netflix
um I depend on your expectations and
what you want I don't I don't think so
um
you know they're they're usually paying
a license fee for the right to do it so
you know what you're getting going in
um
it's a badge of honor these days to say
you're you've got to film on Netflix
um
you know I think some clients if they're
staring at a
um a minimal offer from Netflix versus
someone who wanted to put the film in 10
theaters
you know they have to choose a path
and depending on what they want out of
the film they might choose the
theatrical path because they just want
that kind of treatment
[Music]
um
but there have been some deals like um I
currently negotiate a deal with a
different streamer where we sold the
streamer
um a pay window they're going to take it
they're paying a license fee and another
distributor is going to come in and take
all the other rights and assume that
contract
so they're going to do the theatrical do
the
transactional video then it's going to
go to that streamer that bought the film
and then go to
um other other platforms later
um
and the same distributor was going to
pay a lot less
beforehand when they didn't know about
the the TV deal
so they got their cake their cake and
they eat it too so to speak because they
got
um the I can't say the name yet but the
the cable deal that they're getting and
they're getting someone to take it out
on 10 screens theatrically so
that's a win-win in that case
what are the pathways to getting a film
on Netflix these days
so there's there's pitching into the
originals division to see if it's say
something they want to take on directly
from the filmmaker or you can be with a
distributor who then after they take it
out on transactional VOD will then try
to pitch it to Netflix at the same time
they might pitch HBO Hulu and other
streamers to see if they want to take it
usually 90 to 120 days after the start
of the transactional video window
so there's really two paths there's
either directly we can sell it directly
or through a distributor as a window
later on
and cannot me as an individual just
contact Netflix could concise just send
them a letter and my experience is not
really
um
um just from
that's not to prohibit anybody from
trying or who knows if you've got the
right Moxie to get in the door right
um but um my experience is that
filmmakers come to me have tried have
not been able to get someone to watch it
so it's similar to what you were talking
about with the the need for a producer
rep in that some doors are closed yeah
some doors are open maybe they shouldn't
be but the ones that are closed
sometimes there's reasons and then you
you do those might actually be the best
ones to try absolutely yeah okay
interesting so if if they know someone
or if um the distributor that they've
gone with has access
that's usually how it's done yeah or
smaller yeah exactly
and do most Distributors promise that or
they entertain it but they don't promise
it
um both
um there's some Distributors that that
say
will say yes we're going to pitch it to
Netflix and HBO Etc
that same distributor might also want to
film but say hey we want it but we're
probably not going to be able to make a
deal with HBO or Netflix if they're
being honest
um there are some Distributors that
um on the lower side of the spectrum
that don't even try because they don't
have the relationships they're smaller
Distributors that just can't that take
films out to the transactional vosd
space and the advertising video do you
use space but don't have the
relationships to make a deal with
Netflix or Hulu Etc
um
and then there are some Distributors
that kind of pretend they have the
relationship and just say that they can
pitch them and really can't
how does an indie filmmaker get in
Netflix original
well so there's kind of two ways one is
if you've somehow managed to pitch it to
Netflix and they want to make it with
you normally to get that pitch you've
got to be going in with someone who's
made a film with them before
they and most
Hollywood based
Distributors and just don't have an open
door policy for anybody to just come in
and Pitch anything most of them
including Netflix make films with
the production companies that are owned
by stars or just producers that have
been making films for a long time
and so your most likely path is getting
involved with one of them getting
somehow getting them to look at your
material and having them want to make it
and take it in to get financing from
Netflix
um
that's one way the other way is to pitch
it to Netflix
to the original department and have them
like what you already made
and decide hey we'll we'll make it we'll
turn into an original
it seems like they're taking a lot of or
they're making a lot of adaptations
Netflix or at least the ones I've been
watching are yeah yeah they make all
different kinds of content now it's uh
from reality to documentaries and
they're you know they're
they analyze their the metrics they have
to see what their viewers want dictates
you know what they make
um and who they make thumbs with
yeah you know I've suggested several
films because you know they have this
email thing that you can just put in
would you like to you know a title we
don't have that you'd like to see and
right unfortunately I haven't seen them
up there but you know I keep trying and
I have no personal investment in it I
just want to see it on there but um do
you ever uh recommend a filmmaker go
with just a strict Netflix deal rather
than theatrical
[Music]
um
um you know
I'm usually following the lead of the
filmmaker on that and trying to see what
their goals are and try to advise them
according to what the what they want
and I can point out
depending on what's being offered
what I what I subjectively think is the
best math monetarily
as in terms of maximizing the value was
the best bet
um but if you want a certain kind of
exposure what's the other you know
what's the other mean because there's
all levels of theatrical
um from one screen to 10 screens to 100
screens you know so it kind of depends
on what's being proffered
um
um and kind of depends on what I think
the filmmaker you know wants out of it
at the end of the day
when you see exposure are they also
considering future projects down the
line getting their name out there maybe
is more important than getting someone
to see movie A it's about maybe movie b
or c that's coming yeah I find you know
most filmmakers have
competing goals
um that aren't necessarily at odds with
each other but you know many of them
will say well it's most important for me
to get my money back for my investors
but it's also just as important for me
to make my get my next project off the
ground
um
so I've really declared that they've got
two important most important things you
know at the end of the day
um
I'd say and then it kind of depends
because there are some people who have
financed their own thing so they have
kind of they definitely have both things
in mind there are some people I'm
dealing with where they have there's the
executive producer that I never meet
and but they're in control of the
property and they're much more concerned
about
you know that going on to the next thing
then maybe their executive producer is
so you know and then I get sometimes the
executive producer is part of the
discussion so they're having to pay
attention to that person and and really
the goal is monetization I find that
though usually the best situation for
exposure matches the best
um
um path for monetization is usually not
um it's pretty rare to have that
um
Netflix offer versus
semi-wide theatrical where you think wow
the money's kind of equal
the exposure is kind of equal
it's usually usually someone you know is
is putting up something that's a lot
better than everybody else
well filmmakers make more money from
Netflix or 2B so it depends on the film
Netflix mostly pays license fees for
films straight payments and here's what
will you know pay you for your film and
we'll get it for this length of time and
that's it
um two we can do that too now they have
paid
um upfront monies
um but to be mostly works with
distributors
so like I don't I don't pitch to be
because I just don't find they're really
that interested in taking on
true Independent films directly from
filmmakers or from reps
um
so they're more part of the mix with
what the Distributors doing at the end
of the day and so most films most true
Indies are not getting the Netflix deal
but getting on 2B
so they're making more money by default
from 2B on their films if they were to
get it if if they if Netflix did buy the
film and then eventually it got on 2B
um
it could be that it could be that the
Netflix deal was so good that they'll
never make as much money on 2B as they
did for that deal or it could be a small
license fee and then it takes off on 2B
because it's the right kind of content
for 2B
um so yeah it just kind of depends it's
not really a very uh straightforward
answer to that really
working filmmakers go to make the most
money on their films so I would say
the in general
[Music]
most people are going to make the most
money through all rights Distributors to
handle all these various platforms and
maximize all the platforms as best they
can for the filmmaker
um
you know ideally you get a big fat
license fee from a streamer
um
ideally you get a lot or or ideally you
get a large minimum guarantee a payment
up front from your distributor to handle
the rights which they'll recoup from
revenues later
um but that doesn't happen for most
movies
um so and most movies don't get the
direct-to-streaming deal so most movies
get the All rights distribution digital
and sales deals that are out there
and for me
unless you want to put on the hat of
self-distribution for six months to a
year
um and you have the right kind of film
for self-distribution
the path of going that way with an all
rights distributor is the best way to go
on the other hand if you've made a
documentary
about
dogs
and you have
great contacts with
organizations that are devoted to dogs
saving dogs rescue organizations
lovers of dogs on in social media groups
and you've cultivated over that time or
you're willing to go and cultivate that
and there are
there are people out there that can help
you do that there's a couple of great
you know kind of self-distribution gurus
out there that are great at teaching you
how to
maximize the that the value out of that
kind of film
um and there have been a couple
filmmakers I said well you've got the
kind of film you should probably do that
with
rather than going through me and trying
to get traditional distribution
um but for the most part if you've made
a comedy drama Thriller horror or family
film
a narrative film or a documentary that
doesn't have a knee like that kind of
Niche that you and and you don't have a
self-distribution hat that you want to
put on self-devision is not the thing to
do like it's a overwhelming undertaking
and it's and it's got its own risk is
not foolproof you can go out there and
do all those things this those
self-distribution things and it not work
as well but as long as you're happy with
that and that's the thing you want to do
that that could be the option for some
some filmmakers but overwhelmingly most
people are going to maximize the value
of their film by going into an all-rise
distributor that handles all the various
rights
what if you have a Christmas film or a
women in Peril slash women in power
whatever they're called now
so
um
so there's lots of there's lots of
options for both of those genres
um kind of depends on the quality of the
film and how it comes out
um but the
uh both of those are in demand
internationally
um both of those you have to sell it at
the right time of year though because
you need a long lead time like most
Christmas films
um are released in November
um to be released in November you have
to made your deal with someone by you
know August or so
so the best time to sell I mean truly
the best time to sell a Christmas film
is probably May
um because then you're giving your
distributor a lot of time to really get
everything going and geared up properly
for that release in November
um
but you see Christmas films on Netflix
and on
all the different streamers and
theatrical and you know it's definitely
if you pull it off it's uh
it's it's definitely
um
I think there's lower like there's a
margin for error there there isn't with
other films
same with well I think women in Peril
Thrillers there's also a margin of error
there like you can the film doesn't have
to be quite as good in order to make
money because it's a such desired
um genre
and that's overseas as well as domestic
yeah oh wow for both of those
interesting what is the
self-distribution Hat just in a nutshell
what what is that so
[Music]
um
there are different methodologies that
different people teach on on how to
self-distribute a movie
and that usually
involves trying to identify groups out
there that would have natural
inclination to dig your film
and then whether it's going whether it's
going after those people on social media
directly and trying to Market directly
to them
or it's creating Partnerships with
organizations that have the same cause
and doing free screenings with those
people in order to create word of mouth
and then sell to their you know have
them in exchange for doing a free
screening they Market to their the the
larger group of people in their
organization
um
that's the way I've seen a couple of
people what a couple of
self-distribution gurus
um teaching these days in terms of
techniques to try to
um but it takes a lot of time and effort
and it's a different mindset you know
that a lot of film most of my filmmakers
like okay I'm done with my job I want to
distribute or distribute the movie
um and don't have the and don't want to
spend six months to they want to they
want that movie to get out and make
money and they want to get under they
want to be creative and make the next
project and they don't have that you
know salesmanship marketing
and you really got to get after it I
mean in order to make it work it's not
as easy as like finding a group on dog
lovers on social media and then just
send them a message you got to really
engage with them and get them and
connect with them and over time
um make yourself well known to them and
and become a part of that culture almost
in order to do that kind of
self-distribution there are a couple
anomalies of filmmakers that
managed to get some money in order to
help do their own self-distribution of a
non-documentary film where it was a a
comedy or a thriller
but usually it took it when they did it
they managed to pre-sell they they had
someone that pre-sold rights to a
foreign territory and they took that
money or they got money from some a
Sundance or some company entity that was
just wanting to support them and they
poured that money into a theatrical
release
and either they booked the theater
themselves and figured out how to do
that or they hired a Booker and then
then perhaps they really most of them do
end up doing a deal with a distributor
though at that point they handle all the
various digital rights rather than going
through an aggregator so most
most successful self-distribution of
non-documentaries that I've seen have
been pretty well funded to do a
theatrical and that helped the overall
picture of the film
how many filmmakers do you know who make
a living making movies so I've had
several clients who have gone on to you
know great careers in making films
um I sold Chaka King's first film
newlyweeds who went on to do Judas in
the Messiah one of Mike Flanagan's early
films Absentia who now made this the the
um The Shining
um
uh SQL
um and lots of other great horror films
and and series for Netflix
um I I co-produced and helped sell
several films with Ron Bergman who's a
producer he's now partnered with Ryan
Johnson and they did um
Star Wars 8 and
um Looper and several other knives out
and several other great films
um so I have a handful of clients that
have gone on to to have you know great
Hollywood careers
um I have a few clients as well that
still make movies are still trying to
make that one that graduates to the
studio level but still making indie
films
um
some
some still very Indie some kind of in
the Quasi Hollywood Indie world of
catching talent and having sales agents
you know pre-sell their move movies
there's lots of those movies that kind
of out there that don't bubble up but
still kind of make money in strange ways
um
and um
and then there's a lot of people that
are one and done
um just because it was so such a big
effort to get that first one out there
and
um they just never could get quite back
to making number two
um that's partly because it's just hard
to make a film that makes money and um
and I think it's it's easier when you're
young I like to bootstrap it and do it
for nothing and get all call in all your
favors but it's hard to call in the
favors twice
um so yeah it's definitely a mix
sure and if you have debt from the movie
yeah
um
that's difficult yeah
yeah so and most people I know I think
most films I rep
were mostly equity
most of them tend to be have found an
equity investor to make the film as
opposed to renting their credit cards so
it's not debt per se and that they have
to pay it back they just have
disgruntled
investors maybe but um
or not overly happy but um
but um
yeah I think
it's uh yeah it's just it's just not
it's not easy to make a movie and it's
um
I'd say
you know me I don't know what the
percentages are but I'd say probably 70
percent 80 percent you know don't go on
to make a second film at least
well that's that's high that's
unfortunate but
yeah well there's just a lot of stuff
that I mean we've got a lot of movies
out there and it's not that like they
don't go on to do great things other
ways right like it's you know
um see I've definitely had clients like
like wow I made this film but I'm never
doing it again
like they that's the way they feel after
after making for one like it's just it
was a lot to to get that one off the
ground whatever that felt like to them
so
yeah it's not always a sad story it's
sometimes just what they choose they
just choose A New Path right they got it
out of their system yeah yeah exactly
what's the budget range of the movies
you typically work with
yeah the range is micro to like almost
nothing to
several million
three four million
I'm
maybe a couple times I've had seven
million dollar films but pretty rare
how does a half million dollar movie
make its money back
so
um there are lots of potential ways to
make it back but
um
for a half million dollar movie
you most likely need to
get it into a major Festival
and have someone
pay you that and more back up front
because if you most half million dollar
films don't make their money back
so
that's you know
it's just half a million dollars it you
know implies no cast really right
um
that I mean when I say no Castle I mean
there are people in the movie but
there's no names in the movie per se
that help sell it
and that's you're going up against a lot
of independent films out there that have
names that were made at two million
dollars and even those movies don't get
sometimes don't get a half million
dollars for their U.S sale
so you're really up against it it's
really it's tough
but I have had plenty of half million
dollar movies that made
you know a hundred thousand in the
transactional VOD world the distributor
managed to sell
to uh
cable entity for a couple hundred
thousand and then it made more money on
avod to get to that half million dollar
number
um you know I'm sorry avod sorry
advertising video on demand and that's
where the ads play that's where the ads
oh and you can't expect okay great sorry
um
are there certain films that are
domestically made but they are hits
overseas but they're not here
it's pretty rare these days
um the one of the reasons I decided to
get into domestic sales as a producer
rep as opposed to International sales
was I saw it going down
um 15 years ago
um
um you know there was a day when
International sales was Major and talk
about we're talking about true Indies
here okay not there's still a market
overseas for films with names in
quasi-independent films made by
Hollywood production companies we talk
about true indie films
um there's barely a market now overseas
and that's partly because at one point
we we used to be able to sell almost
anything overseas 25 years ago
the this is you know there were cable
channels around the world and
um video stores around the world that
needed content
and U.S producers were the only ones
that could make them at a price
and we were the only ones really doing
it in mass and so we were flooding the
world with our content
so fast forward past you know um
the writer strike creates the reality
television and the cross cost of
production all comes down
and countries around the world start
making their own content for their own
communities
there's just not there's just no Demand
anymore at all for True Independent
films
um
there's still a pretty good
I almost say good but there's still a
business for films into three million
dollars in up range
that are made you know in not with that
with the studio but independently in
Hollywood with a name attached to it
where they can make sales around the
world that come up to 50 to 70 percent
of a budget
but that doesn't exist for True
Independence
even if they get someone and they pay
them a day rate maybe they weren't
they're not an a-lister but they're
recognizable yeah these days you it's
like to me for for sales purposes it's
really A-list or nothing
um I think when you're when you're if
you're gonna
if you're casting for name value and
it's that level you should also be
making you should possibly really
uh be getting them because they're
really great for the role
um much more important than what their
name value is and you're hoping that the
combination of them being
um great for the role
and a little bit of name value catapults
it into another sphere then the you
everything else out there
um
but yeah I see a lot of films that cast
B level talent I should say not level
but you know value Talent
um
for that purpose and it just doesn't
didn't make a difference
right I'm just thinking of overseas as
well so it sounds like maybe 15 16 20
years ago yeah we could do that easily
back then there was a you know it was a
day when you could just tell an
international distributor oh I've got so
and so in it and and they just believed
you right and that they didn't even know
that the person had value
or not
and that's how you know that's how
Westworld it was at one point you know
um or Wild
um but they're all much more
sophisticated now
um they all know exactly what they need
and what their audiences want and who's
worth what and so it's it's really kind
of
you know again there's
again going back to those three million
dollar level films where you know there
are some actors that have kind of popped
up in value because they were in big
Studio films and so there's a certain
recognizability there's certain name
value that's still there but they're not
getting
you know they're not leading roles in in
big Studio movies they still are trying
out for them maybe they're trying to be
the next Marvel guy or whatever but
they're not getting it but they still
have some value so for a few years
they'll be castable in that kind of
budget range
and usually in Thrillers or horror films
or you know elevated horror you know
something very commercial
action as well
um
but um
but it's uh
but that list is pretty it's a pretty
small list and it changes
and it's subjective too I find that like
just because one sales company has an
affinity
for one level one actor
with a little bit of name value they
might have that Affinity because they
had a film last year that they sold with
him that did well
but the sales agent over here doesn't
have that experience
and doesn't didn't hasn't made a film
with that guy so they don't have this
put the same value on him that that
other company does
so it's not like a you know a where like
you can't rely on IMDb scores
um for Value they really you know
sometimes they correlate but most of the
time they don't because people pop up
and down on that list
um pretty wildly now
this faith-based films is the only place
to sell them is to certain Networks
yeah I'm not that conversant and
faith-based stuff I've never sold a
faith-based film
um from what I understand
um
you know there's a mega church that kind
of
um there's one or two of them that have
done you know quite a good job in the
past of
of of creating these faith-based films
for their
um their audiences and and Screen those
films for the churches as a way to
create a Groundswell for selling off the
ancillary rights later
um
and um
and and I think that there's
um their faith-based production
companies that have kind of figured out
the formula and the name value that they
need and can kind of and know how to do
that
um
but if someone came to me with a face
faith-based film I'd say hey you know
um if it if it also works for a secular
audience I know where to go with it but
if it's purely faith-based and very or
very overtly faith-based there's better
there's there's routes that I don't
really know that much about
how does film negotiation work
so usually if a um distributor wants a
film
um they'll reach out with terms
um either you know everybody does a
little bit differently some people
um will poke at me and say well what do
you want
um some will just send me an email
saying
um okay here's the here's what we would
do for the film here's the distribution
fee and then either they have a a term
sheet or they just type it into an email
um
um usually the next step is I present
that to my filmmaker
um
explain the company to them and what
what they're about
introduce them to them so they can hear
from the horse's mouth so the
distributor can tell them exactly what
they were going to do with the film and
how much they like the film Etc
and then we repeat that process with any
other offers coming in
then I usually try to help the client
make a decision in terms of which way
they want to go
and then depending on which way they
want to go there are some Distributors
that have come at us exactly where they
want to be and I just know from
experience there's no negotiation
they've come at me with the lowest
distribution fee they ever offer the
lowest cap on expenses they'll do the
less term they'll do and
um and then there are some companies I
know that they've come at me a little
higher than what they'll do and I know
what the wiggle room is ahead of time
um and so depending on who the client is
chosen I'll tell them okay well here's
where I think we can move the contract
on this
if they give me the green light then I
usually call the distributor and say hey
here's they like you best but only if uh
you can make these terms
um and then if they agree then we're
good and we go to a long form and then
there's a long form to negotiate as well
but usually I've seen most of the long
forms for all the companies that I've
dealt with and some of them I've
redlined it before and already got a
pound of Flash and I know exactly what
they're gonna you know what they're
gonna agree to or not so there really is
no need to get into that in order to
make the deal we can just make a deal
based on the deal memo or the email
and then um and then worry about the
long form after the fact
um
and if they don't come to if they don't
agree to whatever I'm proffering in
terms of a counter I go back to the
client say well they wouldn't go down do
you want to
you want to try them again or you want
to respond to their counter to our
counter or do you want to go given that
do you want to try the other person
because maybe they're more amenable and
maybe you like them more now that you've
heard that they won't do what you want
to do and so then I'll go and but
usually only negotiate with one at a
time
um it's just you don't negotiate with
two entities at the same time because if
they both accept you if you gave them if
you counted both of them they both said
yes then you've um
you've committed fraud so you don't want
to do that so you only deal with one at
a time until there's an acceptance of an
offer then you then you have a deal
and sorry a term sheet is what
a term sheet usually
um
um is just a either piece of paper or a
PDF that has the basic terms of an
agreement not all the language of the
agreement
so it'll spell out usually a term sheet
will have the length of the contract
the rights the maybe not all the
like it'll say
um video on demand rights DVD and
Blu-ray rights advertising video and
demand rights it's what rights they're
taking
but it won't have a description of each
right which will be in the long form
agreement
um it'll have the term
um it'll have the
um if there's a minimum guarantee that
they're going to pay against the rights
against against the revenues then
that'll be in the term sheet
um and then
beyond the major things
um the depending on the distributor they
might have
um how the you know just a quick couple
lines on how they do accounting a quick
couple lines on expenses and whether
they cap them or not
and so there might be a couple things to
flesh out in the term sheet depending on
how specific or or not specific term
sheet is
um before we go to long form to make
sure okay we don't want to agree to this
because there's a little ambiguity in
the term sheet in terms of like
accounting rights so let's be sure that
what we mean here is quarterly for two
years not just or quarterly for the
whole time or what you want to be you
know as specific as possible before you
say yes
um but some of that I already know
because I've seen their long forms
before so we can we can work off just
the basic terms in order to make it a
deal
so it's almost like a cliff notes yeah
for the okay and then the long form is
is how many pages usually
uh depends on the distributor
um some it can be
five or six pages
some it can be 26 30 pages
um some of them have agreements where
they have kind of the basic terms in the
first three or four pages
and then what's called a standard terms
and conditions document that's kind of
stapled to it that kind of gets into the
nitty-gritty of everything defining all
the terms defining all the rights and
all those things
so
um
it depends it depends on the company to
a certain degree how lengthy it is
and what what is the usual the standard
length of term
or does it vary depending it does vary
the the range is 3 to 15.
oh Years Years
um
you do you do see 20 even from bigger
deals
but they're plunking down a lot of money
they're really making it their film
um
I would say most of my deals are in the
seven year range
usually we're negotiating down from 15
to seven but then there are a couple
companies they're more aggressive and do
like three years
um
but you find that all companies have you
know executive there that's like well we
never do below three years or we never
do below seven it had their own standard
that they just won't you know they just
won't go below because
and I find that most companies that want
longer terms
the reason they want longer terms or a
couple one is
they have these big libraries and they
want if new ways to release films come
out on the market they want to have this
huge library of films that they can
monetize that new way so for instance
advertising video and demand or avod is
relatively new platform
so all these companies that had all
these movies suddenly had a whole other
way to monetizing these films and if
they had only had three years
there'd be four or five years of films
that they didn't have to put through
this these platforms
um
another reason is it looks better on
your books to have long terms so if
someone's evaluating of a bank is
evaluating your company
um if you're trying to sell it to
someone and you have you know 20 films
for three years
they think well geez in three years this
is nothing you know like so and if and
anyone I could be able to monetize it
with a new platform that comes around
like like if avod you know or something
like it
um so
um there are assets on the books of
these Bank of these companies so Banks
just value them more if they have longer
terms on their contracts interesting and
is it reasonable to expect the longer
the terms of the contract the more or
the possibility of an advance
no not really
um
well um I should say maybe
the the companies are doing three years
are not doing advances yeah so I guess I
guess yes is actually the answer to that
question so the companies are doing 7 10
15 years are more likely to do advances
[Music]
um
and I think that's I think that's
because they just don't have to be as
aggressive as the three-year they're
usually offering a little bit more than
the companies that are doing three years
they haven't longer they've been around
longer
um they might be doing theatrical on
some of their movies they just have you
know bigger pipeline
um
yeah they're a little bit more they're
not having to be as aggressive
to get films than the companies that are
doing the three-year terms yeah I think
the movies that I've watched on 2B these
were all films that have been out for 20
plus years so yeah that makes sense yeah
that would be the case for you know
wanting them to on their I don't know
they want them on their books but
establish names from filmmakers that
have been around yeah exactly why does
slam dance co-founder and filmmaker Dan
mervish call you a shrewd negotiator
um because I paid him okay all right
that's good I don't know I um uh Dan's a
great friend I I met him early on in the
in the days of slam dance
um because I think I attended the second
slam dance
um and been going ever since
and I've had
every year I have two to four movies at
slam dance
and then at some point I struck up a
friendship with Dan's been so long I
don't remember when
and then
um
I remember even when he you know when he
was going around with his second film
I read it gave him some comments on it I
don't think anything to do with that one
and then later on I've sold a couple
I've sold now two films for him and kind
of consulted him on another one and
um and Dan's a very you know Dan is a
little much more knowledgeable than your
average Indie filmmaker
um so he's definitely a big part of the
process when I'm helping when I when I
have helped him sell a film and
um
and so there's a shorthand there too and
so I think he I think more than anybody
he knows a little bit more than my
average client what I know
um and how helpful I can be and so
like like I said there are some people
like you know Dan Dan could probably
take the time and do what I do and get
everybody to watch the film
it might it might take longer because he
he's not doing it year round like I am
and I think that's why any and because I
stare at it I know all these things he
knows by experience what I know
um
and um and yeah then it comes in
negotiation
um that's fun because it's uh we we go
back and forth in terms of like how
we're going to try to
um influence the buyer that he likes to
do do the best by it so
how do you negotiate the best deal for a
movie
um
well
to a certain degree
um
I you know I think that
most films I'm working on
are going to this certain level of
distributor and there's only a certain
range that we're going to be negotiating
and I already know going in
what the best position that these
negotiations will do for really any film
if it hits that range
so there's some films where
um
I just know exactly where they'll go
I know where they won't go and it's it's
more about communicating the filmmaker
like here your here are your options
here's how we can kind of push a little
bit or pull a little bit
um
it does get more interesting when
it's a it's a it gets above that level
and we're getting theatrical offered
and
um
and I I find that
it's best to go to Distributors with the
position of hey they really want to be
with you but here's what you got to do
um I'm not a fan of like
you know say well so and so wants it you
know are you going to beat them
um I'm not a fan of um
um
telling people what we want upfront
usually if a Disturbia comes to me and
says well what do you want I'm saying I
usually say we want the best possible
deal
um
because I don't want to undersell it you
know I want them to come to me with the
best possible thing
um there's a little bit of that
um
I guess I've been doing it so much and
so I I don't find it that complicated a
lot of it's intuitive
um and a lot of it's just knowing
knowing who I'm dealing with pretty well
and
um and knowing where they'll go where
they won't
so you're not trying any well you know
if you don't let us know in five days I
have X Y and Z over here that they want
it and you know you'd be crazy to lose
after this
just doesn't work yeah it just doesn't
um
and especially since I'm you know I mean
maybe if I was just a one-off
person and they didn't know me
um and had no history of dealing with me
but almost everybody I'm selling films
to I've sold two films for a couple
decades you know so
um
it's uh there's it's there's it's a lot
more
um
it's a lot more straightforward and like
like this is really the you know I also
know since I know where they'll
potentially go I know where they won't
go
I know not to go to them with
something crazy that they won't do
um
and I have in situations where filmmaker
is like well push him anyway you know
like hey you know they won't pay in
advance but ask for one anyway and I'll
do it I don't care
um but I'm always right I mean they're
not good to you know they're not going
to do what I know they're not going to
do
um
I don't think I've ever been surprised
that way
um another rule of thumb there is that
if someone's you know if someone's made
an advance offer an mg offer then
they're probably movable on it a little
bit
if if but not not a hundred percent
greater than what they've offered so
they've offered you twenty thousand
they're probably not going to forty
they might go to 25 or 30. that that's a
generalization
if they offered nothing
they're probably not offering anything
they're probably not moving even to one
thousand dollars because that's just not
the way they see it this transaction
so it's just knowing those things I
think that helps
the negotiation
so you you pretty much know the rules of
the game the players in the game and
where those films are going to plug in
and there's probably not a lot of leeway
like you said if someone's not going to
give a minimum guarantee they're
probably not going to do a thousand or
Twenty Thousand for one right exactly
um that's not to say I am surprised by
who wants what though
and it's not like I like I'm
I'm selling the film right now to HBO I
didn't know HBO was going to want the
movie
or pay a good license fee for it I had
no idea
um and my my next best offer was not
even close
to what they offered so it's not that I
know what's going to happen I just know
once they make the offer I know
I know where they'll go and where they
won't go
how often are these negotiations in
person and how often are they via email
Skype yeah they're all a combination of
zoom and and email and phone
um even pre-covered
um overwhelmingly unless you're
selling film at Sundance
um they were selling the film The
Sundance or South by Southwest and it's
in person then you're going to a condo
and you're meeting meeting people in
person
um
if um there have been times though I
guess
there are occasions though where I have
had filmmakers go to meet distributors
in Los Angeles
um as part of the process you know
pre-covid
um but I don't need to be there because
I'm just putting them together to meet
in order to talk creative and what they
do for the film
um and then the negotiation will happen
by phone or or by email afterwards
because so much of it needs to be in
writing
yeah there's just no reason to get
together you know like there's no reason
to get in a car and drive 30 minutes to
just do what you can do
um pretty you know more efficiently by
by phone or email
can you explain a deal memo
um Dillman was a term sheet
at the end of the day so Dil memo is the
basic terms of a deal
um the term the length of the the
contract the minimum guarantee if
they're going to pay something up front
for the movie The number of years the
rights they're going to take and then
some of the other factors that they
every demo is a little bit or term
sheets a little bit different in terms
of what they'll
um they'll put out there in terms of
what they are you know it's kind of a
it's like you said earlier Cliff Notes
version of the contract okay sorry I
didn't realize the deal member was the
same thing it's termites okay maybe you
said that okay without naming names
what's the worst distribution deal
you've seen a distributor offer one of
your films
laughs
um
that's a great question
well certainly not one that I ever would
allow someone to take
um
it usually
when I see a bad one it has to do with
how revenues are shared
and they're just the Distributors just
taking too much
um
there are some deals where
there's some Distributors out there
that use other Distributors to get their
films out into the marketplace
um and so
they're taking a percentage
after
the distributor who's doing the work is
taking a percentage after iTunes has
taken a percentage
right so when from iTunes to distributor
to distributor to you
and some distributors
small these are smaller companies don't
disclose it
uh and say Hey you know this is our
distribution fee but just so you know
we're also going through this other
company
there are companies though that do
legitimately and say okay this is our
distribution fee and it's inclusive of
the Distribution Company that is
actually doing the work they're getting
it out there
or they'll say it is on top of and yes
it's a big fee but
but that's what we that's the way we do
it it's just a little bit more
legitimate than hiding it right so the
worst deal is is the combination of the
fact that it's fee on top of a fee and
they're not revealing they're just going
to give you a royalty statement that
says what came in
and what they took from it without
explaining that another level of Revenue
went from one person to another person
that came to them
that makes sense
why would a filmmaker even I mean why
would a company even think that a
filmmaker would entertain
it's like an extra middle man it's not
just a middle man it sounds like a well
again some people don't reveal it and
they don't know that's the familiar
doesn't know to ask the question ah
right and
um okay there I do know one company that
will reveal it if you ask them
but they don't reveal it if they don't
if you don't ask them
which and it's just really strange
because I like without naming names I
like a lot of things about these people
they're really they do other things kind
of right but that one aspect of it I
like
why why like and I guess it's because
probably because they're not winning
movies
because they have to re that when they
do reveal that some people filmers are
like well I can't give you a percentage
on top of another percentage
um and I know another company though
that what they figured out to do is to
make the company that they go through
have their fee inclusive of their fee so
the fee that they're proffering it might
be more like 30 35 because they're
having to account for giving 15 to
someone else but at least
you know it's it's more competitive
than charging 25 on top of 20.
right
um
so you do get different kinds out there
but
overwhelmingly most of my films
all
almost all of my films
almost 100 go through companies that
there's just one fee being paid taken
out
um
there's
there's one distributor I go through
who takes a fee but has it inclusive of
this company he's going through and he's
a
he's an honorable ex-studio guy who was
very straightforward about what he does
and essentially the way the the
conundrum that Distributors that people
have when they've become a dis they want
to become a distributor is how do I get
to Market
right because anybody I could go
tomorrow and say hey I'm a distributor
you give me the movie and I go put it on
iTunes through a lab I just pay the
encoding fee really easy
what's harder
is to sell at the cablevod
and to establish a distribution
relationship with the streamers and
established relationship with 2B and the
other advertising video on demand
companies that's harder to do
and so what some people decide is hey I
want to distribute movies but I don't
have those relationships I'll create a
partnership with a bigger company I'll
go to the cost of acquiring and
marketing the movies and we'll just have
a relationship with this company where
they are the ones who put it on the
platforms and do the sales
and that's fine
if you're above board about it
and your fee isn't too and you're able
to do a fee structure that Inc that
doesn't take too much out of the dollar
but if it's if you don't reveal it
quasi-criminal to me
um it's not criminal but it's
very unethical
um and
um
and then and then just the fee structure
is just crazy you know like if you do a
fee on top of fee it's just like how do
you how do you make any money
it's very hard
so if a filmmaker was doing the DIY
wearing the distribution hat themselves
and and they've been approached or they
approached someone and they don't
realize this is not that there's not
just one Phoebe how are they going to
uncover that what kind of clues or paper
trail or how are they going to do a
search
to see so
um
some platforms like Amazon and others
have in the details of the film
they'll have like the copyright date and
a little bit of information and some of
them have the distributor name
and so if the distributor isn't your
distributor
most likely they put it through somebody
else oh wow right but that would be too
late at that point oh yeah
there's a there's a
um
there are definitely a lot of there are
a lot of companies that
just don't do it
properly one way or another
um and I just don't send them my movies
it's showing me easily easily handled
that way sure it's real fun you know
it's sort of this omitting very
important information yeah interesting
so that it would be very difficult until
you get to a point where you can't even
get out of the contract it sounds like
yeah I mean like I said like
distribution contracts are hard to get
out of
they're not they're not built to be easy
to get out of
and um
especially if you're working with
someone
who didn't tell you everything up front
about how they do business
most likely they don't really care if
you want to get out either
right that's the kind of person they are
so
um that's why it's very important
if if you are diying it if you are going
to distributors
or producer reps or anybody you should
be checking IMDb and calling those
filmmakers and and trying to get enough
of them to tell you what their
experiences were so that you can make a
you know a little bit of an educated
decision on on where to go sure and even
in doing that you can still run into
problems
and 100 so people know each other they
could be friends they could have
alliances yeah it's real tricky but yeah
that's interesting I I did not know that
so that's
for for filmmakers that um
you know because in that that there's a
bigger chunk being taken out because
there's this extra person that's right